with air travel inching back from its
collapse during the pandemic
americans might be able to fly to europe
this summer that is
if you're vaccinated exactly how this
new era of pandemic travel will work
is still up in the air but there's one
approach a lot of people are talking
about
vaccine passports call the passports
vaccine passports
a covet passport the so-called vaccine
passports or digital health pass systems
aim to revive the tourism industry allow
people to attend concerts and events
and get back to the office but creating
a coordinated health pass system is so
fraught with logistical and ethical
conflicts
that it could take years to pull off
startups non-profits and governments
have already rolled out different kinds
of digital health passes
from israel's green pass to an app that
allows access to holy sites in mecca
but so far there's no single pass that's
used all across the world
so what would it take for digital health
passes to get people back in the air
again
and out in the world
this is really an unprecedented
situation
in you know the modern global economy
julie wernell reports on the impact of
covet 19 on business for the wall street
journal
really the goal of these systems is to
make people feel safe enough to resume
normal everyday activities
everything from eating inside at a
restaurant
or going to a concert venue or traveling
the idea is to have an official digital
record of your coveted history that when
you travel
authorities can check and determine how
likely it is that you're carrying the
virus
the big challenge is making something
that's accepted across
borders and stays updated with other
countries coveted regulations
several groups including privacy
advocates businesses and healthcare
providers have proposed solutions
one of those stakeholders is dakota
gruner she is leading a coalition of
over 150 partners
including all the major health pass
providers to create a set of global
standards to underpin
digital health passes she says there are
a few main features
every digital health pass should have
the first is something called
interoperability meaning it should work
across different institutions and
borders
a person can be you know tested or
vaccinated
wherever it is that they live and you
know get to
an airport or get to um you know
a border and have that past be
you know sort of seamlessly recognized
and trusted say you're traveling from
new york to london
a successful app would tell you the
latest guidelines for both cities
and integrate your official coveted
health records from each country
airlines are trying out different
options like common pass verifly
and iota travel pass but most trials are
limited to select routes
and passengers aren't required to use
the pass so it's hard to tell how it
would work on a mass scale
the reality is that so far you know
we're not really seeing this in a very
mandatory way
very many places because people don't
even know
how to mandate it and they don't know
what
counts as proof or evidence that you've
been vaccinated
also key to health passes according to
gruner are verifiable health records
these include things like vaccine
certificates as well as past coveted
test results in past cases
if you can have both proof of testing or
proof vaccination that allows people
sort of flexibility and sort of how
they if if they can't be vaccinated you
know perhaps they can be tested
in a digital health path system health
records would need to be uploaded to the
app and accessible to different
authorities
like physicians or border agents for
different uses
experts say consumers should be in
control of how much health data they
share
and with whom for example you might
choose to share more health information
with the doctor giving you your second
vaccine dose and less data with the
airline you're checking in with at the
airport
we think that this idea of selective
disclosure is really important
because it would allow me to share just
the minimum information
necessary when that information is
shared authorities need to know that
they can trust it
that's where another key factor comes in
verifiable credentials
and that is you know literally sort of a
packet of data
um that has it is verified um you know
that you can say
i this has been signed and sealed and i
sort of know that the
the packet of data has not been tampered
with and i know
who it was who's attesting to this
packet of data
but in order for digital health passes
to be embraced by both government and
regular people
they need to address the ongoing debate
over data privacy
in america privacy and health privacy
has always been a huge
hot button issue and people are
concerned
about sharing even that amount of
information and want to know that that
record is safe
some groups have been advocating for
centralizing health data since before
covid19
but resistance to sharing this data has
extended to the current pandemic
several states including texas have
banned having to show proof of
vaccination
including vaccine passports government
should not require any texan to show
proof of vaccination and reveal private
health information just to go about
their daily lives
cyber security experts in israel's
public health union have raised concerns
about sharing sensitive health data
this is a messy ecosystem there are a
huge number of potential
issuers of a health pass you know
testing centers
vaccinators states and also a huge
number of potential verifiers
um you know the airlines
you know border control agencies
workplaces and employers are also
considering tracking health records
one mercer survey found that almost 51
of companies are either currently
tracking their employees vaccination
status
or are considering it while individual
states are taking different approaches
to regulating vaccine passports
big tech is laying out some guidelines
for kovid related apps too
apple has said kovit 19 app developers
need to work with recognized government
or health authorities before submitting
to apple
and google has a list of additional
requirements for kovid 19 apps going
into its play store
still because there are so many apps out
there right now
the exact privacy policy could vary
slightly from each app
what's more some health officials
contend that tech companies are
over complicating the process and this
health information can be stored in a
much simpler form
like in a qr code and there are bigger
questions about how these apps will be
used together
some apps like the iata travelpass and
verifly are focused on the travel
industry
while others like israel's green pass or
new york's excelsior pass
are being used to grant people access to
events or spaces
the concern that essentially by asking
people to
prove that they've been vaccinated in
order to do very
you know normal things like go to work
or
attend a concert that we're creating a
system
in which there are two classes of people
the vaccinated and the unvaccinated
policy is as important as the technology
um and we need policy makers to define
the range of acceptable use cases
um you know and specifically you know
sort of
define what is not an acceptable use
case for a health pass
exactly where that line is is still
being worked out
and finding that balance is going to be
crucial for international travel
business and public health you